the collective wisdom of all of
humankind led to the medical
advancements that made us modern we are
attacking the things that harm us on a
microscopic level we're finding new ways
of preventing disease every day the
question is how far can we go what seems
to be fantasy and sci-fi in the world of
health in the human body is actually
just right around the corner imagine
having your own personal catalog of
replacement tissue sitting on a shelf we
can tweak ask info and turn it into a
brain cell and rebuild your body parts
that's the horizon and it's not far away
it's not fifty years away it's going on
right now this lab is to genetics what
the printing press was to written work
here in this lab we synthesized DNA so a
lot of people have heard about the Human
Genome Project where DNA was coded but
here what we're doing is actually
building pieces of DNA the DNA code in
every cell it's not only a source of
information for example your eye color
your hair color your height but also
source of control of different processes
in your body
things like regenerating cells at
different speeds in different parts of
your body it's an incredible incredible
technology our overarching goal is
making DNA ubiquitous to make it
available to everyone the things that
we're working on right now we know can
be game-changing better more specific
drugs personalized drugs we're enabling
a lot of different types of projects but
I always like to think about the people
that are studying cancer there's been a
lot of cancer in my family cancer is a
very dynamic disease but if you can
accelerate research then you can
actually create a designer therapy for a
specific tumor and faster you can do
that the earlier you can intervene and
not everything in cancer in the world of
synthetic biology it's either going to
be the thing that saved humanity or the
thing that kills humanity so we're part
of an organization that self polices in
the industry we have different protocols
to ensure that none of us will design
and build something harmful to humanity
and I think as we think about medicine
this is the next revolution in medicine
this is the ability to really create
personalized medicine it's an
opportunity to help humankind
[Music]